In previous videos, you could see us renovating an old pickup.
We also got a new container, and installed a big roof on it.
Our workspace team is now getting into a new fascinating project!
Remember the yellow van?
It's been here since Season 1!
In this video, we are going to renovate it,
and make it into a long-term living space.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
This old German post-office van
was one of the first additions to Basekamp!
It was donated by our friend Mattia during Season 1.
But, after two years,  its state is a bit - let's say - rough...
Yeah, the van is rusting, and falling kind of apart...
It has some leaks...
Problems with the electricity...
It's not insulated, and it is not fully leveled...
So, this year we decided to give it a bit more care,
to make it more useful, and more comfy, for the people that come.
The van, originally, was designed to be a campervan.
But, realistically, this is not going to drive much more...
So, we want to adapt it to our new setup.
We want to redistribute all the furniture that is in the van.
And, with that, we want to reuse as much materials
as we can, from the old setup.
All of this means a lot of work for us!
But, in another case, the van would end up in a scrapyard,
and we don't like that...
So, for us, it's worth to take the challenge,
and effort, to make it happen!
Luckily, we come with the help of Jaime, Mariona, and Kevin.
You already know Jaime, but let me introduce you to Kevin and Mariona!
Hey there! I'm Mariona!
I'm 26 years old, and I come from a little town, close to Barcelona.
I'm a product designer, and have worked on it for some years now.
I came to Project Kamp, because I believe in
a more sustainable way of life and work.
All of this, and surrounded by nature!
I love the sea, dancing under the rain, and swimming in waterfalls.
I also like sewing, repairing clothes, and I am interested in how
to produce new materials out of organic waste.
Believe it, or not, but we can create material from this orange peel!
To be honest, the future is kind of blurry for me...
I go step by step, figuring out of what comes next.
But, for sure, I am learning along the way,
from the amazing people I meet!
Hello! My name is Kevin!
I'm 36 years old, and I come from Hong Kong!
I'm an upcycling designer, and my focus is on creating
new objects with waste material.
I like bringing surprises to people, with materials that are often overlooked.
Now, I'm at Project Kamp, because I believe there's a way
we can live without harming the environment.
In the future, I would like to bring the inspiration I found here,
back to the society where I came from.
But, now, I'm quite excited to be here,
and help the project with my skills!
See ya!
Okay, so, the first thing for this project,
is going to be levelling the van.
The van has been standing on old tires,
and they keep losing air...
So, it's going out of level...
So, the first thing is to put the van on wooden blocks,
and getting it level to start building.
The first thing we do is cutting the stone into four pieces.
Wow!
Done - it's done!
That was the last one?
- Yes! Done, done!
Nice!
We just finished leveling the van!
And, as you can see, all four wheels are floating in the air right now!
So, it doesn't matter if they have no pressure.
They are now standing on four big wood beams.
And, it's, it's totally levelled!
So, now, it's time for the fun part!
Let's go rip everything out!
An emergency box, someone?
- Give me that
There's another frame underneath!
So, here we are!
We have everything from the van sorted!
Wood from the floor, wood from the walls...
We will try to reuse everything,
and that's why they are all sorted so tidally.
A lot of Styrofoam, which we have no idea what to do with...
So, I guess, a lot of research needs to be done.
- Looks good eh?
It's empty!
It's not that bad...
It could be worse.
I was expecting it worse, actually...
Nests.
And, it's full of wasps, yeah?
- Uh, I don't think so...
- At least one...
I see two already!
- There are six! There were six!
Now you fit, fully! Did you fit before?
- This is the same roof, huh?
- But the floor.
- But the floor was like this, about five centimeters...
I have a little bit more.
So, we already took everything apart...
We ripped everything out, and the last thing is to take the solar system out...
- I'm taking the wires out...
Not for now...
It's stuck somewhere...
And now, where is it going to?
It's coming up!... Yay!
Another one!
So, okay, I've been trying to take
this metal wall out, with this tiny grinder...
It's not working at all, so, it's time for the big one!
Not enough...
No way...
Want a sock?
It's nice...
So, now, we are gonna measure the inside of the van.
We're gonna have a top view drawing,
and then we can decide where to put everything.
The distribution of the new house!
And, yeah, that's what we're going to do now!
- Like, from there...
Yeah, exactly!
Now, that we have all the measurements,
we will start designing the layout.
It will take some days to figure out
the best distribution for our interior...
Anyway, it seems like the three of us have a similar idea.
Cool! Let's see how it goes!
- We have the same layout!
Okay, so, now that the van is cleaned, and everything
is ripped apart, we want to bring power to the van.
So, we're gonna dig a trench,
all the way from the pizza hut to the van.
So, that the van has power...
Oh my God...
- Almost?
- Here...
Yes!
- Woo!
We got it!
- It's out...
- A little bit more
That's it.
Okay, so, this door doesn't open from the outside...
So, we were thinking about fixing it, but it's too complicated....
And, we also found this old door!
So, we're gonna try fit this door in this opening.
Our next step is to build a frame
for the door, and try to fit the door in the opening.
So, we want to use this door for the van,
and put it in the frame we just made.
Before we can do that, we have to cut it to size.
We also have to turn around the hinges...
And, because we're turning around the hinges,
we have to turn around the lock.
So, I wanted to reuse the lock from the door.
I tried to turn it around, but I broke it...
Sometimes this happens...
I'll tell Adrian to get another one, and we will install it later.
So, meanwhile, let's continue with the door.
Woah, I don't recognise it!
Okay, so, right now, we are on the roof of the yellow van.
As you can see, the fiberglass is looking pretty bad...
It's bended, it's leaking everywhere, and it's falling apart.
It has been fixed a few times,
but the fixes are not the best, as you can see...
So, we have to take a drastic decision,
and we have to cut all of the roof out.
Yeah, so, we are wearing a lot of protection,
because we are going to cut the fiberglass on the roof.
And, once we cut the fiber, it will be flying all around...
That's why we are having extra protection!
- A mask...
- And, some glasses.
How are you, guys?
- I want to take this off!
Yeah...
- It's so hot!
I'm dripping already!
The dust isn't as bad as we described it...
- The dust is okay.
- Yeah, it's not that bad.
-  But still, I prefer wearing all this stuff,
because if you get fiberglass on your skin...
- You're gonna be regretting it for two weeks.
- It sounds like I want to try a bit.
- Yeah?
- Never try!
- Go for it...
Are you okay?
- I'm okay, I'm okay!
- Hi Jaime! Say hi!
Hello!
- How is it?
Hot! Very hot!
But, it worked!
It's done!
Better than we thought.
Easier than we thought.
New house!
- Yeah, I like the new roof!
- Much more open, sunlight, natural light is good!
- Yeah, that's how we keep it!
Oof, that was wild!
Now, we have a completely empty campervan!
We still don't know what we will do with the old roof, but let's see!
For now, we are done with this update.
In the next video, we will finish the van,
with the new roof, the interior, and details!
If you want to watch it now, and without ads,
you can support us on Patreon!
If not, you can subscribe, and help us with the algorithm.
Thanks for watching, and see you in the next update!